grüße meine lieben untergebenen weg zu
ich habe folgende fragen sich warum hast
du dich als erste der großen deutschen
youtuber dazu entschlossen die ich mir
zu unterwerfen das war aber ein ganz
schlechtes video oder billige qualität
hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gehört
und ich gesehen also wirklich also ich
finde der sollte sich wirklich
nie wirklich also ist er mir nein spaß
also hatte max beziehungsweise um ein
imperator ja ich bin ich auf jeden fall
oder ich habe mich auf den von
unterworfen weil du ein großartiger
berater mit großartigen zielen hass und
ist ja klar dass man sich da nur
unterwerfen kann